♪ ♪
>> Greg: AS SCHOOL BOARDS MOVE
TOWARD THE LEFT, CONCERNED
PARENTS GIVE THEM AN F.
BETWEEN MASS MINUTES, CORTICAL
ACE THEORY -- GENDER POLICIES
MORE CONFUSING THAN RuPAUL
BUYING DRINKS AT LADIES' NIGHT,
PARENTS HAVE A LOT TO BE PISSED
OFF ABOUT.
BUT MERRICK GARLAND IS LEADING
THE WAR AGAINST MOM AND DAD.
HE'S GOT MORE ISSUES WITH
PARENTS THAN BRITNEY SPEARS.
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS GRILLED HIM
OVER HIS HORRID MEMO DIRECTING
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
REVIEW THREATS AGAINST SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS.
GARLAND TRY TO CLARIFY, BUT DOUG
A DEEPER HOLE.
>> THE VERY FIRST SENTENCE OF
YOUR MEMO, YOU SAID IN RECENT
MONTHS THERE'S BEEN A DISTURBING
SPIKE IN HARASSMENT, THREATS OF
VIOLENCE.
WHEN DID YOU FIRST RESUME THE
DATA SHOWING THIS SO-CALLED
DISTURBING UP TO?
>> I READ THE LETTER AND WE HAVE
BEEN SEEING OVER TIME --
>> I DIDN'T ASK YOU -- YOU READ
THE LETTER, THAT'S YOUR SOURCE?
IS THERE SOME STUDY, SOME
EFFORT, SOME INVESTIGATION THAT
SOMEONE DID THAT SAID THERE'S A
DISTURBING UPTICK OR YOU JUST
TAKE THE WORD OF THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION?
>> THE NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION, WHICH REPRESENTS
DOZENS OF SCHOOL BOARDS AND
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS, SAYS THERE
ARE THESE KIND OF THREATS.
>> Greg: SO LET'S TARGET
PARENTS BASED ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION LETTER
DEMANDING THAT HE TARGET
PARENTS.
THIS ISN'T BASED ON ANY ACTUAL
DATA, NO FACTS, NO STATS, NO
CASES, JUST A LETTER.
THAT'S PRETTY SCARY, AND IF
YOU'RE SCARED, YOU SHOULD BE.
ONE A GROUP PEOPLE CAN WRITE A
LETTER TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
DEMANDING YOU GET TARGETED AND
HE AGREES, THAT IS SOME
SERIOUSLY BAD [BLEEP].
I MIGHT --
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE.
I MIGHT TRY THAT ON MY NEIGHBOR,
WHO KEEPS PLAYING COLDPLAY.
I HATE COLDPLAY.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, PARENTS IN
MICHIGAN AND VIRGINIA FILED A
LAWSUIT TRYING TO CRIMINALIZE --
IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH, THE CDC
SAYS SCHOOLS SHOULD KEEP MASK
MANDATES EVEN IF THE KIDS ARE
VACCINATED, SO MR. PRESIDENT,
WHAT'S UP WITH THIS WAR ON
PARENTS?
>> LOOK, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE
PARENTS ARE SO UPSET ABOUT.
BUT THE SCHOOLS DO THE TEACHING,
ALL RIGHT?
YOU'RE NOT AN EXPERT IN HOW TO
RAISE YOUR KIDS.
LOOK, THEY TEACH THE FOUR R'S,
READING, WRITING, RITHMATIC,
VACCINES.
AND YOU KNOW THE SONG.
SCHOOL DAYS SCHOOL DAYS, DEAR
OLD GOLDEN RULE DAYS.
WHAT'S THE GOLDEN RULE?
WEAR A MASK!
>> Greg: HEATHER, I WAS JUST
SAYING, WE DON'T HAVE A WAR ON
CHRISTMAS ANYMORE, WE NEED A NEW
WAR AND I THINK THEY JUST
DELIVERED ONE, IT'S THE WAR ON
PARENTS AND THE PARENTS HAVE TO
AT SOME POINT GALVANIZE BECAUSE
THEIR KIDS ARE LIKE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT, BUT...
YOU HAVE KIDS.
>> YES.
I'M ONE OF THOSE MOMS AND I
THINK THE WORLD OF MY
DAUGHTER -- EVERYONE THINKS THAT
THEIR KIDS ARE THE BEST IN THE
WORLD.
OF COURSE, WE ARE ALL BIASED AS
PARENTS.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, THIS IS A BIG
PUSH TO TAKE AWAY POWER FROM
PARENTS AND SHOUT OUT TO ALL
THOSE THAT ARE SPEAKING UP
AGAINST THIS.
FOR EXAMPLE, CRITICAL RACE
THEORY IS DIVISIVE, IT'S
UN-AMERICAN, IT'S VERY
DESTRUCTIVE, AND I THINK THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD STAY
OUT OF IT.
YOU LEAVE IT UP TO THE STATES,
AND THAT WAY YOU KEEP THE
AUTHORITY WITH THE PARENTS,
WHERE IF YOU DON'T WANT YOUR
CHILD TO GO TO THAT SCHOOL, THEY
CAN GO TO A DIFFERENT SCHOOL.
AND HERE'S WHERE IT'S REALLY
HURTING DEMOCRATS IN THE POLLS.
YOU LOOK AT AND VIRGINIA,
TERRY McAULIFFE, HIS POLL
NUMBERS ARE TAN